the two ukrainian journalists have just
been named as the recipients of dw's
freedom of speech award for 2022. video
journalist mr slav chernov and
photographer jenny malaletka of the
associated press spent 20 days in
mariupol under constant bombardment the
last international journalists left
mariupol they risked their lives daily
to record and send out footage
documenting the war in a city cut off
from the outside world the dw freedom of
speech award honours
honours people who have been have done
outstanding in their efforts to promote
freedom of expression and report the
truth a warning to our viewers this
report does include some distressing
images and we won't have video
statements from the laureates for safety
reasons they didn't want to be
interviewed on camera
a city's agony that's how mrs lavchernov
and evgeny maloletka described what they
witnessed in mario paul
arrived in the strategic port one hour
before the war broke out early on
february 24th
people were soon dying all around
doctors battled to save children
newborns and adults often without
success
hakeev-born video journalist mitis
levchernov has covered wars in iraq
syria and many more countries working
for the associated press
photographer evgeny maruletka is also
from ukraine's east from beriansk both
have won multiple awards for their work
as russian bombs rained down on mariopol
the telephone radio and television
towers were destroyed
with no phone signal people couldn't
even call an ambulance doctors begged
the journalists to film families
bringing in their own dead and wounded
so the world would know what was
happening
many of the bodies had to be buried in
mass graves that galvanized the
journalists to take ever greater risks
with no pictures of demolished buildings
and dying children says mr slav chernov
the russian forces could do whatever
they wanted if not for us there would be
nothing i have never felt that breaking
the silence was so important
the journalist footage of a russian
attack on a maternity clinic on march
9th was a turning point
the images of traumatized families being
rescued by ukrainian soldiers prompted
an international outcry over russia's
disregard for civilian life
this pregnant woman carried out on a
stretcher later died
along with her child
moscow claims the whole thing was staged
with actors
and the airstrike never took place
russia now broadcasts its propaganda
over radio and mario paul accusing
ukrainians of holding the city hostage
and shooting at buildings
with russian forces searching for the
two journalists they managed to escape
mariopol on march 15th
with the help of the ukrainian army
we were told that if we were captured by
the russians they would force us to say
what they wanted us to say into the
camera evgeny malaletka told dw
i didn't want to experience firsthand
how the russian intelligence services
deal with people who are detained
the pair continue to report on the war
in ukraine from elsewhere in the country
dw's director general peter limberg is
in the studio with me mr limburg welcome
uh there are so many journalists
reporting in ukraine why what
distinguishes these two and how hard is
it to choose them
everyone has to say that there are
really a lot of great and really brave
war reporters in ukraine and uh rebecca
you were among them you were in kiev you
just returned so
um but i think uh
the two um channel and madoletka they
they did something special being being
in a place where nobody else was and
they
they didn't leave it
they just stayed there because because
they
knew as we saw also in the report that
if they don't bring light into this uh
nobody nobody will care
and so i think this is an amazing brave
attitude towards our profession and i
think this is uh why they deserve this
award
yeah i was just rereading their story uh
yesterday they wrote something for the
associated press afterwards and then
they were actually forcibly evacuated by
the ukrainians because their life was at
such risk i mean it's an incredible
story um what message are you or dw
trying to send to other journalists with
this year's prize
i think it's also recognition for war
reporters and reporters who
go into dangerous places because we all
know it journalism has become much more
dangerous in the past years but
this war is another
example for this and all the wars which
we have been covering uh whether it's
syria or whether it's uh some wards
far away from europe shows us that you
have to have free press on the ground
otherwise people do a horrendous things
and
so i think this is why we say that it's
it's important that we have these
journalists when they are well educated
and trained i mean we don't send people
into crisis situations who have not
special training and we do everything to
protect them but i think it's absolutely
vital to be on the ground
you mentioned press freedom there and i
wanted to touch on
russia the russian government cracking
down on free media
deutsche was among those forced out of
the country earlier this year um how do
you see
those developments in russia
oh we see russia turning into a
kind of fascist
rule
where freedom of press is erased totally
and it's pure propaganda coming out of
every russian outlet
so it is a situation where i think that
journalism is is very hard to do
and we all see that there are a lot of
russians going into exile russian
journalists and we see
that we are opening our bureau now in
riga
in latvia so that they have more access
and be near
to russia but uh it's getting uh
difficult and i think for the coming
month and years it will not get better
well then i'll end on coming back to our
prize winners because this is really
about them how difficult was it to
choose those two particular
men
i think
it wasn't so difficult because it is
really something special outstanding
they changed history because people
could see what's going on for the first
time and they saw the brutality of
what's going on and so i think uh it
wasn't so difficult we chose the right
ones i think
peter limberg thank you very much for
your time welcome rebecca thank you